Silicon Valley is in its final season
anything you want - you know I don't
want any spoilers because I love the
show when I'm up to date right now but I
know there's a bunch of episodes still
coming anything you can tell us or what
subscribe to promote to promote this the
windup of this great series well I will
say this I think Silicon Valley you know
I love that show and I definitely want
to promote it but I feel that so often
it's these sort of big-ticket television
projects that get promoted and that that
there's smaller more subtle movies that
don't get their day they don't get their
promotion so what I just said little
little thin little projects yeah I
decided I wanted to vote my time on the
show today to promote a little movie
called Ford versus Ferrari and I don't
know if you guys are familiar with it I
haven't seen it and I haven't seen the
trailer but
based on the synopsis that I wrote
online it's about Gerald Ford gets in a
fight with an Italian person and no
that's I I was just kidding no but it's
really about it's it's one of the Fast
and Furious franchise and Vin Diesel Vin
Diesel plays Christian Bale Matt Damon
plays himself okay and they funded it it
was made by they had a Kickstarter they
sold this way they sold raisins on the
subway raisins on the subway okay so
basically you're trying to get the word
out on on the movie Ford versus Ferrari
yes because Silicon Valley is already on
HBO it has a platform who's gonna see
Ford versus Ferrari unless I promote it
and I just think are you guys excited
for Ford vs. Ferrari
[Applause]
the studio apart
well that's I'm that's a lot of great
publicity you just gave a movie which I
believe not to disagree with you has a
ton of I can't go anywhere in this town
without seeing a poster for Ford versus
Ferrari listen I just think I just think
it needs more attention and I feel that
I also feel it's on for me and you know
if you ask anyone in the world about me
the first thing they'll say is I don't
know who you're talking about but the
second thing they'll say is that guy's a
gearhead he lives for the grease he
lives I guess okay okay do we do have I
think we have a Silicon Valley clip do
we have a Silicon Valley clip there is
no Ford versus Ferrari clip available no
if there is what Matt Damon was here
like a week ago and showed a Ford versus
Ferrari clip and seemed to feel like the
movie was well promoted he has to act
confident because it's all bluster on
his partner he's trying to get it off
the ground and god bless him I have to
do Silicon Valley they brought a clip
which is Jared over the course of the
the series has alluded frequently to his
sort of dark past in the foster care
system all yes difficult family
situations and for this is a little bit
of a spoiler bit but coming up he he
discovers that his birth parents are
alive oh and he meets them he thought
they were long dead and that and that he
had no family but he meets them and he
goes to investigate from whence he came
and so that's what this clip is let's
take a look at this could not from Ford
versus fright but from Silicon Valley
take a look
you guys had kids after me well one was
after party Pete and Lisa were before
you
I don't understand you I was her third
child and you kiddin me yeah yeah just
got way too difficult for us couldn't go
on as many flights to parents to kids
that's a clear row across no one a B C
and D so you give me up to simplify your
first class air travel
[Applause]